Today I'm talking to Jonathan Passagio
who I think is touched with more than a
little bit of genius and he's a
Quebecois artists and a carver,
a sculptor,
and I'd like to start by letting
Jonathan tell us who he is and what he
does.
Okay.
So yeah,
I'm a,
I'm an icon carver,
which means that I make,
I make carving for churches and for
people of traditional images.
So I get commissions and I,
and I work within a traditional language
of,
of Christian art.
I've been doing that for about five
years now,
full time.
And before that I actually lived in
Africa for seven years working with
artisans.
They're trying to help them,
uh,
in their business practices and their,
their design skills.
So I have a very kind of strange and
varied background.
I studied fine arts at Concordia
University here in Montreal.
In the.
Yeah,
in the late nineties.
So yeah,
full time icon carvers.
Do you suppose there are in Canada and
in Canada there the.
I'm the only one we're about actually in
the,
in the entire world where we're very
few.
I actually know most of them.
Yeah,
it doesn't sound like a very easy thing
to monetize.
So how did,
how in the world did you go from being
a,
an art student trained at Concordia to
being a carver of icons?
I studied painting and drawing at
Concordia on the surface.
I was doing really well.
I actually finished first in my,
in my class,
but there was a malaise the whole time I
was working there because I'm a
Christian.
I grew up,
I grew up a Christian and I was trying
to figure out how that would connect to
my art practice.
Uh,
and so I was,
I was looking,
trying to figure out symbolic languages
and in painting and trying to find ways
to talk about bigger,
bigger questions,
metaphysical ideas in my paintings,
but I didn't have the language so I was
really just groping around almost blind
and uh,
yeah,
it.
And at the end of my time at Concordia,
the professor who was supervising me,
she,
she basically said on the very last day
she said,
what are you doing here?
This is not,
this is not the place for you.
After that I,
it kind of left me dangling,
you know,
and,
and a questioning a lot of things.
So what sort of education did you get a
concordia?
All the fine arts programs now in,
in I think pretty much almost 100
percent are based on contemporary art
practices and so very few universities,
very few programs teach a technical
skills or teach you how to draw in a,
in a classical way so they actually not
really teaching anything.
It's hard to know exactly what they're
doing.
I guess it was ever since the 19 sixties
through speeding this idea in the art
world that technical skills and ability
just aren't that important and that the
important thing is to find your,
I would say your political voice,
but it's very strange to me that this
has occurred because it seems to me that
before your voice is anything but a,
an off color Croak,
you have to become a disciple of a
discipline and an apprenticeship and
learn the tools and trades of craft and
learn how to be an artist because
there's a technical end to that.
I mean,
this is really almost an image of the
world as it stands now.
The,
the,
the purpose or the stated purpose of,
of,
of modern efficient,
postmodern art was to free the artist,
right to break,
to break away all the things that were
holding the artist back in terms of
rules and in terms of,
of,
uh,
just the way things were presented.
But when ended up happening is that
there were no more legitimate
legitimizing objective or you know,
strong legitimizing structures around
the art.
The only thing left was politics and
relationships and status basically.
So our funders,
there's a big literature on creativity
and it's strongly,
which I know very well.
My lab designed the creative achievement
questionnaire which is used.
It's been used in hundreds of studies
now to assess lifetime creativity.
And so I've spent a lot of time looking
at the measurement of creativity and
also trying to understand creativity.
And the literature strongly suggest that
when you impose restrictions on people,
it actually makes them more creative
rather than less.
Because part of what creativity is the
overcoming of obstacles.
You know,
imagine someone who writes poetry and
the Haiku format,
well,
it's,
it's very,
very restrictive and obviously
arbitrarily sold,
but the fact of the restriction is
partly what makes the poetic form
possible.
The same thing is true.
If you think about playing a game,
there's a,
there's far more things that you can't
do when you play chess than there are
things that you can do,
but there's still an infinite number of
variations of chess games.
So this idea that there's a dichotomy
between structure and rules and
creativity is,
is pernicious Lee false and contradicted
by the evidence
when you,
when you start to explore the art world
and the way it works is there's an irony
there that it purports to not have
boundaries on creativity and structures
on Tina,
but they're actually extremely strict
and they're hidden.
They're,
they're kind of this pernicious thing
underneath where we're actually you,
you have to present things in a very,
very precise way for it to be able to,
to enter into the legitimizing structure
of the,
of the gallery,
the,
the.
It's like the message that I was trying
to work on.
And the,
um,
the,
the structure of contemporary artists
didn't fit together.
And so at some point I gave up on art.
I,
I had to work,
you know,
I had a studio and I closed it down.
I just destroyed all my paintings.
It was,
it was actually a moment of,
of kind of spiritual crisis for me.
And it's in that,
in that moment that I discovered many
medieval art,
I discovered traditional Christian art.
And when I discovered traditional
Christian art,
it was exactly what you were saying
before,
the forms of Christian artwork kind of
developed as a community would say as a,
the Christian community develop these
forms that were actually extremely
powerful and,
and,
and created like a,
a cosmic map basically.
And so you could use,
you could use these images as a type of
Algebra to create a sacred,
a sacred language.
And so discovering that,
yeah,
I just felt like,
it gave me so much possibility.
Well,
you're going back
like 800 years,
900 years into the history,
maybe even farther than that,
back into the history of traditional
art.
So you say you discovered Christian
iconography and I also know that you're,
you're,
you're an Orthodox Christian,
which is a strange thing for a
quebecois.
So I don't know,
you're a pretty rare bird,
so maybe you could,
you could say a few words about the
discovery of the iconography,
how that came about and also how it is
that you converted to Orthodox
Christianity.
Well,
I mean those two things are very
intricately related.
I think during,
during university,
just like a lot of people,
I,
I kind of got into an intellectual and
spiritual crisis.
I was reading data and,
and all the postmodern theorists trying
to wrap my head around this,
like what does this mean for me and what
is it?
What is going on?
Um,
and,
and it's in that kind of crazy time that
I started reading the church fathers
and,
and reading more traditional breeding,
more traditional authors,
people who talk about traditions in
different,
different cultures and realizing that
this was really the solution for,
for me at least,
it was a solution to kind of get out,
get out of the chaos that,
that,
that the modern world that kind of
fallen into.
And so it,
when it came with the art,
so looking at the art and seeing the
patterns emerge and seeing that those
patterns in the art were the same as you
find in scripture and the same that you
find in liturgy in the same that you
find in the stories that are around us,
even stories that aren't actually
Christian to see those patterns emerge
is what really caught my attention.
And,
and,
and so I was looking at first,
I wasn't necessarily going to be
Orthodox.
I could see the patterns coming through
and I was trying,
you know,
trying to figure out and I couldn't find
them in my own meat,
which is which I grew up evangelical.
Uh,
and so I,
I was looking for it,
I couldn't find it,
I looked at Catholicism,
but finally I,
I felt that I am looking at Orthodox.
I felt like Orthodoxy was the type of
Christianity that had preserved the most
of that ancient worldview and was still
living at today.
So it's a,
it's a living tradition.
It,
you know,
when you say you went back 800 years in
a way that's true,
but it's not true for the Orthodox
because they continue to perpetuate
those,
those forums until today.
I mean,
not that they didn't go through rocky
times,
obviously it's been crazy for orthodoxy
as well,
but for some reason they've been able to
constantly revive their forums,
you know,
and today it's a thriving,
a thriving part of Christianity.
Well,
you know,
this idea of,
of this,
of this return,
um,
and,
and the continual revivification of
traditional forms reminds me of two
things.
It reminds me of the old Egyptian
stories about horace and Noah,
Cyrus and Horus,
the Egyptian God of vision and
attention.
So he's Egyptian,
I,
and the,
and the Falcon.
And after horace defeats Seth,
who's sort of Egyptian precursor to
Satan and reclaims his throne,
he goes down into the underworld to
rescue his father.
Oh Cyrus,
who,
who seth had chopped up into pieces.
And um,
when he's down in the underworld,
he gives,
oh,
cyrus one of his eyes,
which seth has torn out.
He gives him one of his eyes and then
brings them back up to the surface and
they rule Egypt together and the Union
of Osiris and Horus was like the
Pharaoh's soul.
So there's,
there's this ancient idea and it's
expressed in more places than in
Egyptian mythology that it's the duty,
it's the sacred obligation of someone
who's awake to journey to the underworld
and revivified the corpse of his father.
And that not unites the individual with
a living culture and also makes the
culture alive because of course,
culture in some sense because it's the
product of the dad is a dead,
is a dead entity.
It has to be continually revivified by
the living.
And then you see that echoed in more
modern form,
oddly enough,
in a Disney animated movie.
And Pinocchio,
and Pinocchio is the story of the
struggle of a puppet,
a Marionette,
whose strings are being pulled by forces
that he does not understand.
It's the story of his struggle towards
individuality and,
and rebirth.
And a number of things happen to
Pinocchio.
He has to learn not to lie.
He asked to learn not to be a neurotic
victim because that's actually one of
the temptations.
It's that it's,
it's his agreement that he's in neurotic
victim,
that,
that places him on pleasure island,
where he virtually,
where he's in danger of becoming a
jackass and a slave to totalitarians.
Interestingly enough,
after he leaves pleasure island,
he goes to find his father,
but he can't find him.
And a note from the Holy Ghost
essentially tells them that his father
is at the bottom of the ocean,
in the belly of a giant whale.
And the whale is also a dragon.
And so then Pinocchio has to go down to
the bottom of the ocean in his half
jackass form and rescue his father from
the belly of the whale.
And he does that by mastering fire.
And interestingly enough,
in the,
uh,
in the Pinocchio Video,
he's assimilated to the Christian symbol
of the fish in the belly of the,
in the belly of the whale,
Japan,
no couches,
a bunch of fish,
uh,
he thinks to eat them in any couches,
Pinocchio and confuses them with a fish.
Doesn't realize that having caught
Pinocchio,
he's caught his own salvation.
Then they work together to get out of
the whale's belly.
But there's this very old idea that
especially in chaotic times when
everyone's turned into a jackass and a
tool of totalitarians that the way
forward is to journey to the deepest
possible recesses of,
of reality and revivify the farther
something everyone needs to know.
And there's something,
I mean,
we'll see as our conversation continues,
you'll see how,
how,
how for me at least this goes,
is that for
me,
going back into the,
the Christian tradition and,
and,
and reconnecting with the Christian
tradition has actually opened my eyes
also to the world around me.
And so those patterns that I find in my
own tradition,
the patterns that are kind of feeding my
life once they're integrated.
Now when you look around you,
you see them,
they appear everywhere.
The world is actually made of those
patterns and you can recognize,
you can recognize those patterns in
contemporary culture and you watch a
movie and you can see that these,
these are the same patterns,
but it's the best way is like the,
the danger is to,
is to do it in an,
in a,
in a simply in an intellectual way.
I mean,
that's kind of all our danger.
It's connecting to a traditional,
you know,
becoming Orthodox and,
and living it through liturgy,
liturgy.
Um,
when you go to church and you
participate in the liturgy,
you're physically engaging in,
in the sacred patterns.
And so it's,
it's a way to make it almost a bodily
experience.
Right?
Well,
it's interesting,
you know,
the,
the Christian emphasis on the
resurrection of the body,
which is of course something that,
that modern people have very difficult
time with.
I mean,
people can perhaps swallowed the notion
that the soul is immortal,
but the idea of the resurrection of the
body is something that just seems beyond
the Pale.
But there's,
there's a logic to that insistence and
the insistence is that there's something
sacred and necessary about the body and
that it can't be forgotten,
um,
when,
when discussing both spiritual say on
sacred matters.
So it's definitely the loss of the body
that's part of what,
what constitutes part of the rootless
nihilism that characterizes the modern
modern age,
you know,
learned that partly by reading Carl
Rogers because one of the things that
Roger talked about was the necessity.
Young talked about this a lot as well.
The necessity of bringing the body into
alignment with,
with Rogers,
it was more with the voice and he,
he claimed,
for example,
that you could feel with your body
essentially whether or not your words
were aligned properly with your being.
And certainly I've certainly learned
that that's true and that you can learn
to determine when your voice is making
you stronger physically and when it's
making you weaker physically.
A very,
very useful thing to pay attention to.
One of the iconic figures that you've
carved and that you're interested in is
St George.
And I've been very interested in the
figure of St George.
Um,
I think the,
the,
the story that's encapsulated in St
George is certainly one of the oldest
stories known to mankind.
It might be at the core of the oldest
story because basically what it does is
present human being the individual in a,
in a,
in a battle where the individual society
and the individual are being threatened
by the reemergence emergence of are
carnivorous,
Reptilian,
carnivorous Predator.
And I think the roots of the Saint
George story go all the way back to the
time when the distant ancestors of human
beings.
We're living in trees and being and
being preyed upon by predatory snakes.
And that's about $60 million years ago.
Back when there were dinosaurs.
By the way,
an anthropologist named Lynn is bail at
the,
at Ucla,
has done a series of studies showing
that the reason that human beings have
such amazing vision because we can see
better than any other animal except for
birds of prey,
is because our vision evolved to help us
detect predatory snakes in particular as
they crept up on us through the
underbrush.
And she established that by noting that
there was a powerful correlation between
the prevalence of predatory snake
predation in primate populations across
the world and the acuity of primate
vision.
And it's also the case that our vision
evolved just as the story in genesis
suggests,
because of fruit,
because we see colors because we can
detect to detect ripe fruit.
And so genesis insists that human beings
got their vision because of snakes and
fruit.
And that seems exactly right from an
evolutionary perspective,
but you can imagine the idea in St
George,
there's,
there's a,
there's a dragon that reemerge is from,
it's,
it's a layer underground and it's a,
it's an eternal dragon.
Immortal Dragon.
And it threatens the community.
And St George goes out to to fight the
dragon in single combat.
And as a consequence,
he,
he frees a virgin from,
from the snakes grasp,
just like Harry Potter does in the
Second Harry Potter volume when he goes
down underneath hogwarts to free Jenny,
who's the Virgin Virginia from the grips
of the basket lisc.
And the basket risk is the thing that
turns you to stone with a single glance.
And Harry Potter is revivified by the
way,
by the Phoenix.
His tears and the Phoenix produces a
rebirth,
right?
Because this phoenix is a symbol of
death and rebirth.
And so there's St George story is,
is embedded right in the depths of of,
of the Harry Potter Story.
But I think it's predicated on the idea
that human beings,
men in particular forever have been
fighting off the predations of the
natural and the social world,
and the,
the idea that you free the virgin from
the grasp of the serpent is that women
have preferentially chosen to ally
themselves with and mate with men who
are capable of facing the Reptilian
Predator.
And so it's the basic evolutionary story
of mankind that human beings learn to
fight back against predators maybe to
even find them in their layer instead of
waiting for them to attack.
And that women in their gratitude for
that in their gratitude for the
protection of infants.
Like there's often images of Mary
raising Christ
up
out of the way from a predatory reptile.
Right?
And that's in reference to the genesis
comment that this,
that Mary will bruise the head of the
serpent with her heel.
It's an extraordinarily extraordinarily
deep story.
It goes deeper than just the idea of the
serpent too,
because the ultimate serpent in some
sense,
isn't the one that lives in the external
world.
The ultimate serpent might be the one
that's in the heart of your enemies.
Or if you make a metaphysical
transformation in your thinking,
even beyond that,
the ultimate serpent isn't even the one
that lives in the heart of your enemies.
So it's not the natural snake or,
or the crocodile or,
or a Predator like that.
It's not the vicious barbarian that's
come to the gates of your castle to
steal your belongings and make off with
your women.
It's the snake that lives in your heart.
And that's why Christianity insists on
the association between the snake in the
garden of Eden and Satan.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think that if you,
if you,
if you think of of the world in terms
of,
uh,
of macrocosm and microcosm,
the idea that,
that the,
that certain structures repeat
themselves at different levels of
reality,
that's like music,
right?
Then you,
you,
you can think of this idea of a world as
having in the middle,
you know,
a tree or a cross or you know,
something like an access in the center
and as you move away from that access,
you know,
from the access which defines the space
basically like a flag or something like
a post.
As you move away from that center,
you're moving further and further from
what it defines and you're approaching a
chaos.
Basically,
you're,
you're approaching chaos,
which is in the negative sense.
It's chaos,
right?
In the positive sense.
It's also potential.
It's the potential from which that world
will,
will grow.
So it on one side it threatens the
insight,
if you will.
And on the other side,
it is the potential by which that,
that,
that thing will grow.
And so the dragon in the Virgin in,
in St George's story there,
there are actually several versions of
the of the dragon in some virgins and
the most known virgins sent a St George
will kill the dragon,
but there are lesser known versions of
the story where he actually tames the
dragon and the dragon into his pet,
you know,
and there's versions where he tames it
then killed it.
Like there's different versions of the
story,
but it's to show this idea of,
of as you move out,
sometimes there's something on the edge
that that appears on the edge and you
can't define it.
It's this chaotic thing.
It's the dragon in traditional way of
represent representing it isn't just a
reptile.
It's actually a hybrid creature.
It,
it usually has a mix of,
of,
of Lizard and it has hairy feet and
wings.
And so it is,
it's this monster.
It's a monster.
It's an amalgamation of things to be
frightened by,
but also treasure because the dragon
doesn't only guard virgins that guards
treasure,
it's in the.
It's in contact with what you fear and
despise that the treasure is to be
found.
Yeah,
you know in your your notion about the
center point,
say with the flag or the cross reminded
me,
reminded me of the way that children
react with their mother and their home
and so what a child will do when he or
she is exploring the world is make
contact with the mother and that and
that's in the center of the household so
you can think about it as the mother
embedded in society.
The child will will comfort himself with
contact with the mother and then go out
into the world until the point where his
fear overcomes his exploratory tendency
and then on the on that edge he'll play
and further his psychological
development and his mastery of the world
and then when he wears out and maybe
goes beyond his limit,
he runs back to the center point for
comfort and then the next time he goes
out he can go out a little bit farther
and so that.
That structure basically.
That is basically the structure of
everything.
I mean,
yeah,
it's structure of the society.
It's a structure of a family and like
you said,
it's also the structure of an
individual,
uh,
were on the,
on the edges of our person.
We have these desires that exist on the
edge of our person and those desires are
very dangerous because they,
they,
they can lead us into a lot of the mess,
but they're also,
uh,
by the,
the,
the tool by which we further ourselves.
That's very similar again,
to young's idea of the incorporation of
the shadow and also you need,
she's idea of beyond good and evil.
I mean niche you meant by that at least
in part beyond the conceptions of good
and evil that are basically thrown up by
nothing but cowardice,
right?
So you try to make yourself into this
little restricted thing that's basically
the union persona and you define
yourself as good if you never go outside
that little box.
But to be truly good,
you have to go way outside that box.
So if you think,
take this as a,
as a worldview,
I mean basically that,
that has become my own worldview.
It helps you to identify what's
happening around you.
So on the,
on the periphery of the world,
there are these marginal things that
exists kind of in the buffer between,
you know,
order and an absolute chaos and those
things,
they,
they all,
you know,
they rear their heads up and sometimes,
and so we have to have a trend.
We,
we transact with them in different ways,
sometimes tame them.
Sometimes you have to,
you know,
like a dragon,
you have to kill it.
Sometimes you have to just ignore it
too.
Like monsters just have to be left alone
basically.
Like they're too big to,
to,
to deal with.
Yet you just leave them alone.
And to me,
this is really related to what you're
going through right now.
It seems like this is where we are right
now in our society.
Our obsession with liminal things right
now in the world seems to be a sign of
something.
You know,
the word monster actually comes from the
Latin word,
which means to show,
right as a portent.
We in French,
we actually still have the verb
motivate,
which means to show them.
Demonstrate in.
Yeah,
yeah.
There you go.
Demonstrate.
Exactly.
So the word a monster is,
is a portent of something.
It is.
It's like a harbinger of change or
harbinger.
That's something you need to pay
attention because something is
happening.
And so right now to demonstrate to
demonstrate is to de mon straight.
Yes.
Right.
It's to,
it's to take the monster apart and make
it into something that's you can deal
with.
Yes.
That you can master Marduk in the old
Mesopotamian myth because mark who's the
Mesopotamian a hero,
God confronts tire mount who's a monster
and cuts her into pieces and makes the
world.
And actually one of the names of that
the Mesopotamians had was he who makes
interesting and useful things from the
combat with tire mount.
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
I mean so,
so right now we can you look around the,
if you think of a,
of the social manifestations that are
going on,
like just take zombies for example,
like that's the greatest example because
the Zombie is an inbetween figure.
It's something that is neither dead nor
alive.
It's,
it stands in between two categories.
And so,
so the,
in the case of the Zombie,
the Zombie,
because it is in between the categories
is act as a parasite.
It starts to eat the interior.
The brain actually.
Exactly.
Yes.
It's looking for,
for,
for meaning.
It's so he wants to eat the thing that's
inside,
it's trying to devour it.
So the culture,
like the story of,
of,
uh,
of Oedipus and the Sphinx is the perfect
kind of image of this.
So the Sphinx appears as this undefined
monster,
right?
It's a mix of a woman and a lion and a
bird or whatever.
It's this thing that appears.
And so,
and what it is,
it's a question.
It's saying like,
what am I?
Well,
monster,
that is a question or it's an enigma.
The person coming forward is faced with
this enigma and the danger.
So one possibility is that you name the
monster and you're able to integrate it.
The other possibility is that you're
eaten by the monster.
Those two things are a real reality
right on the edge,
on the edge of things.
So when you come to the edge of
something,
you know,
you have this,
this,
this image,
and traditional stories of the bridge.
You come to the end of something and
there's the bridge and on the bridge
there's a,
there's a monster,
and so you have to face this monster
because when,
when you're on the bridge,
you're in a dangerous place.
Your inbetween inbetween categories,
right?
You're in no man's land,
you're in no man's land.
And so the monster comes and wants to
devour you.
So it can be either this idea of the,
the,
the monster asking question,
asking an enigma for you to be able to
cross the bridge.
Um,
and so this is what's happening right
now.
Right?
And so there,
there are some elements that come from
the margins of society which are
standard.
The ones that I've been dealing with or
has been the people who don't fit into
the gender categories.
Yes,
yes.
And so that we're,
we're in a situation where we were
those,
that manifestation of,
of hybridity,
right?
Because because if you look at the
categories that are used,
they are,
they are trying to be the category of
multiplicity itself.
I think they're trying to be the
category.
That's why the categories are
multiplying beyond name.
They started with just nonbinary and now
it's up to 70 on online.
Yeah,
it'd be what it is.
It's a decomposition like it's.
It's a decomposition of a category.
You come to the end of something and it
starts to decompose.
I know in your talks you talk about the
role of the serpent eating its own tail.
Well,
this is my vision of it,
is that when you first see that serpent
youth,
it actually looks like it's the tail
that eating the head and then after a
certain transition,
then it becomes the head eating the
tail.
So imagine the fruit falls on the
ground,
the ground starts to eat it,
it starts to decompose,
and once it's fully decomposed,
then something happens.
There's a flip,
and now the seed starts to use the earth
and eat the earth to,
to become a tree.
And so there's that moment at the end of
something where there's a flip that
happens,
like an inversion and then an inversion
of an inversion that happens.
It's a very chaotic time.
And,
and that's the moment where we,
we,
we are in right now.
And what you're going through,
like the,
the,
the finger that you've,
you've put your finger on something
very,
very critical and that's why there's so
much noise about it is because you're,
you're,
you're standing right in that spot and
you're pointing,
your telling everybody,
pay attention to this monster.
It's right there in front of us.
You talked before with me about two to
biblical stories that shed some light on
this.
And you were talking about Abraham and
the stranger.
And so maybe you could walk through that
because I thought that was an extremely
interesting analysis.
Okay.
So,
so I mean,
the way that in the Bible and in most
traditional societies,
the way that you would deal with the
strange.
Okay?
The thing that comes from the margins,
you know,
it's the stranger in,
in,
in a,
in a global way.
It's this strange thing,
the way we deal with that is through
hospitality,
right?
The first way we deal with it,
The first way we deal with something
coming from the outside and that doesn't
fit into our world is through
hospitality.
So the hospitality,
hospitality means that you receive this
thing as a,
as a stranger,
and there's these implicit rules of how
you interact with them so that there
isn't a mutual destruction basically.
Okay?
And so in the Bible we see those,
those,
uh,
version of,
of good hospitality and bad hospitality
play themselves out.
So in the story of Abraham,
Abraham receives a three strangers and
he received them into his tent and he
feeds them and he gives them,
he received them properly and the
strangers are also acting properly in
his tent.
You know,
they're eating his food,
but they're being respectful of the
house.
They're not stealing things,
they're not trying to seduce his wife
are doing the things that you're not
supposed to do implicitly when you're in
someone else's house.
Um,
and,
and because of that,
the,
the three strangers announced to Abraham
that he's going to have a child.
So Abraham is in his nineties,
you know,
you'd never thought they're angels.
They're secretly,
but they're secretly angels.
That's what's important is that in the
strange,
the strange,
because the strange is an ambiguous,
a category.
It can contain both extremes.
It can contain both the angel and the
devil,
right?
These three angels come to come to him
and they announce that he's going to
have a child.
And so what they do is that the strange
now access this potential that we talked
about,
right?
So it's a fruit defying agent in this,
the case that an orderly structure has
to allow an element of chaos,
an element of the strange into it in
order to become something new and even
to maintain its own survival because
things have to become something new as
they move forward through time,
right?
And so in this,
in that case,
the stranger becomes the,
the,
the means by which Abraham's marriage
is,
is fucked up.
So he grows,
his family,
grows through this bright interaction
with a stranger,
so now these same three strangers,
then they go to a visit,
Abraham's brother lot who's in Sodom and
Gomorrah,
and then although lot receives the
strangers appropriately,
the inhabitants of Sodom and Gomorrah,
they wanted to rape these strangers.
They,
they want to sexually assault the
strangers at end rape them and angels
blind the people around them and they're
able to escape and because of the wrong
interaction and the sexual,
the sexual interaction with the,
with the,
between the stranger and the people of
the city.
If the city is destroyed by fire and
then it leads even further it,
it leads to having an incestuous
relationship with his daughters.
And so it's like the whole world just
kind of,
it collapses because there isn't a
proper approach to,
to,
to hospitality and.
But it,
you know,
and in that story,
you see how it's actually.
So there's an intimation in there too,
is that if the,
if the,
if the interaction with a stranger is
handled properly,
then everything becomes more fruitful.
And if the interaction with a stranger
upsets things,
say as basic,
as basic as,
as sexual interactions between people
than the entire society can become
destroyed.
Exactly.
And,
and that ended,
and I'm using those two stories,
but,
but those two,
those two stories repeat themselves in
all,
all of this.
I mean,
there's so many stories where you see
that often it's not just sex,
it's often food.
There's sex and food.
Those are the two things that the two
major ways in which we integrate the
world.
So for example,
like the story of Hansel and Gretel for
example,
is a,
is a perfect example of where the,
the desire to eat the people that to eat
your,
your guests,
right?
Or for example,
the mother in the Hansel and Gretel
story because she's too good to be true.
And then she's all compassion.
The witch and the Hansel and Gretel
story.
And you can tell that because she has a
ginger,
she's,
she has a gingerbread house.
It's made of candy.
Yeah.
And like a house made of candy is too
good to be true.
That's the social justice warrior
overemphasis on compassion and inside
she's just fattening the kids up,
constantly taking care of them,
but her fundamental wishes to devour
them.
Yeah,
so like an example,
and then one more thing,
they've been abandoned.
Those kids who have been abandoned to
the predations of the evil mothers
because the family broke down like
they're.
It's the stepmother who tells the
farther,
if I remember correctly,
to abandoned the children in the forest.
Yeah.
So it's the breakdown of the family that
leads to the children being threatened
by the eatable mother who's too good to
be true.
She's compassion that's gone completely
beyond.
It's,
it's,
it's tolerable limit cautionary tale,
that's for sure.
You see that,
you see that there's a story there.
There's so many stories of how the,
the,
the relationship between the host and a
stranger goes,
goes wrong.
Like there's an effort and sometimes the
push comes from the host and sometimes
the push can come from the guests.
Like there's a,
there's an Ethiopian tradition where
it's almost an inversion of Abraham's
story were able where a man receives
three guests into his home and the three
guests serve him food,
which,
uh,
which ends up being a human being.
So he,
so he,
they,
they kind of trick the host into
becoming a cannibal.
And then the host becomes like an out of
Control Cannibal.
And you know,
eating people all over the place.
So you can see how the story can go both
ways,
like the,
the,
the relationship with the strange can.
There can be a push from the inside,
from the right hand.
Let's say the order hand,
that can be a push towards,
uh,
that,
that caused the cows.
But it can also come from the guests can
also come from the stranger which can
push from his side or from their side.
And then create the chaos.